So for the remainder of this lesson,
and then the next one.
Oh, and then the next one.
Oh, then the next one too.
We're going to be talking
about motion estimation.
Basically, given a sequence, tell me
what moved, tell me how it moved.
Generally, you can say there are two
different approaches to this.
The first approach,
involves feature-based methods.
Now feature-based methods
are just what you might think.
Extract some visual features
like corners, textured areas.
Oh yeah, we know all about that.
And track them across multiple frames.
So that is find them from
one frame into another.
Oh, we know all about that too.
And that will give you what's
called a sparse motion field.
That is, you you don't have
the motion of all the points.
You have a motion of a bunch of
points that were good to track.
All right?
But that works really well when image
motion is large, so you move like
tens of pixels, and you'll have
a significant change between frames.
The other method class of methods are
what are called direct or dense methods.
In dense methods, you sort of directly
recovering the motion of every pixel
of each pixel from the,
the fancy work is spatio-temporal
image brightness variation.
So another way,
remember that volume X, Y, and T?
So you can think of gradients, you
can think of flow within that volume,
and what you're trying to do is you're
trying to recover that flow based upon
how the appearance changes over time.
It gives you a very dense motion field,
but
it can be sensitive to
appearance changes.
This type of analysis is suitable for
video where you're getting
samples very quickly.
So things don't move very much in time.
And, in fact, if things are somewhat
smooth in time and space, I could say,
well, from one frame to a next, I can
talk about how things are moving, like,
say, a first derivative.
If you're worried that a Taylor series
expansion is in our future today, well,
maybe tomorrow?
Yes, okay.
But the idea is that it's good for
nice, dense, smoothly moving things.